fighting in kihon wasa you're working on
the same
uh principles organizations skill sets
etc but from different sides of the yin
yang values okay
so as i do uh the ishiro tencon
my center is locked my four corners
maintain a relationship
i don't twist
everything is organized so he's pushing
i have the same ground vectoring oh my
keep that same thing
already you're in the center and then
i'm gonna yield
wounds
of course you can see i'm doing the
inward spiral it's the inward spiral
boom
do not move forward into the other
strike boom
here
in boom
up here
don't you're not cutting his arm out of
the way and that's what turns him you're
doing the inward spiral and his whole
body is is being manipulated
um
with your same kind of cue connection so
i'm not cutting his arm out of the way
which is why the thumb is on this side
not my pinky on this side
the thumb is on that side
[Music]
that generates the tsuki which he falls
into
so same thing on the side he goes
oh you're going to go this way
you're not going to twist your body all
up and lose organization
so you keep the same organization so
as i demonstrated i was in his center
in nagas center too okay so he goes
and hoop
keep those four corners organized
boom he's moving up
and i let mine move
he's moving his and i let my move but
we're both keeping them
okay
let's try it
okay so we'll continue on
here
[Music]
so
so there's centrifugal energy going
outward you see
so that means i can generate an ik
adhesion
on this arm i'm not pulling him
he's going out and i keep
a young equivalency on the inside it
will stick
got it we'll stick
oh
boom
you don't need to grab it
feel for that
this energy
i use it
to make a smaller circle inside okay
so you still need an x-pattern in order
to generate the kazushi okay but this is
a way of getting the x pattern by using
a smaller circle inside the larger
circle okay it does generate these
crossing vectors
all right so the larger circle is the
arm circle the arm circle's keeping you
going
okay and the arm circle is in his center
so the arm circles in the center
it's not in his arm as you're moving
you're cutting his arm down
okay
so you keep you got to keep the arm
circle going
and then as he comes to the other half
this circle is going to be a tiny circle
okay
because it's not the two of them going
together it's not they're not the same
size
and centrifugal energy
does it
he said he was the athletic enough he
could turn he could run out of that okay
so
whoa
it's very tight okay
so i'm trying to break it down so you
can see it more so there's the big
circle
big circle
small
oh small
okay so try to have
more complementary angles as opposed to
duplicating angles okay